[Music]
denmark
proposes a ban on selling cigarettes to
people born after 2010. you mean
completely completely if you got if you
were born after 2010 you cannot they're
banning segregated do you say like
illegal denmark denmark what about vapes
why you got to start there we're just
talking about cigarettes
you know i don't know if this is like a
bad or unpopular opinion or whatever but
i'm like i think that's kind of good i
think so too because there's literally
no health benefits to cigarettes right
wait
but the coolness you gain is through the
roof honestly is that worth it though
wait before 2010 because right now it
makes sense because they're underrated
after 2010 after 20. yeah so if you
can't sell cigarettes to people exactly
so they're already they're they're what
12 years old right now so they don't
even know the difference anyway and they
haven't legally been able to buy it and
then the old people would just age
themselves up because they'll die and so
pretty soon it'll be a smokeless country
and to answer your question and nicotine
products in general so vapes
i think for our generation though
smoking was always like seen as the
coolest [ __ ] thing ever like as we
grew up in like movies film tv like yeah
that was just what we saw of yeah like
that was pop culture but nowadays i
don't think cigarettes is that prominent
it's not right you don't you go to a bar
you're a club
and no one goes outside i need a smoke
break yeah anymore
yeah the smoker dude's no longer the
coolest guy around he smells like ass
yeah he just stinks yeah because even
with alcohol right it takes the edge off
chill out you relax like there's some
sort of like benefit like what for
cigarettes i'm like i don't know if
there's like a there's a nicotine buzz
there is a take the edge off from
cigarettes a lot for people mostly
people who have like relied on it
but like smoke breaks and stuff like
that are usually like for friends that
have that do you have smoked cigarettes
in the past they're always just like
[ __ ] need a cigarette
oh god you know what i mean so
you know what's weird about that though
it's because you're addicted to the
poison
so then when you get the poison hit and
then it starts to release so it's like
you know when you get it it is poison
for sure you know when you get like a
thai massage right like a like a thai
lady's beating the [ __ ] out of your back
and in the moment you're like ow right
but then the feeling that you get after
she removes the pain is then when you
feel good so it's the it's that effect
where
uh dude it's crazy man i think i've been
i smoked for over 25 years um when did
you first start i started when i was
like
what is it what fifth grade sixth grade
well fifth grade you must have been so
cool fifth grade is when i tried telling
you coolest sixth grader around fifth
grade is when you know you get into your
friends like dads cigarettes or whatever
and you guys pass around i think fifth
grade is my first puff as well but i
hate it first of all
cigarettes are one of those things
though like you have to try to get
addicted yes because it's disgusting but
you gotta keep [ __ ] trying it unless
you chain smoke on ecstasy i don't know
how it
feels dude
menthol baby yeah i heard i heard you
know new parts is amazing newport
menthols where you got to like crush the
little
i don't know about this but marlboro
blacks all the way bro
is that a thing it was the hardest thing
for me they have blacks you guys used to
yeah i've done every single [ __ ] drug
in the world except for heroin but um
it was the hardest thing to quit to
[ __ ] quit dude that's the hardest
thing you've had to quit out of all of
them yeah dude there's also such
availability and convenience with it
though exactly so your body actually
craves it though
besides heroin like if you're addicted
to heroin not like hopefully you haven't
been addicted i never tried it but i
want to try yeah my body craves that
that your body actually craves it you
know like nicotine your body
yeah and it's it's like this slow killer
right because you just don't
it's like easy to get you can buy it you
can function clearly because like even
an alcoholic you gotta like
get drunk or like you you gotta you know
it's starting some time out it's hard
right like you gotta yeah set a day for
it like even if you're a stoner or
whatever sometimes you're functional but
still costs more
you can basically the the the the buzz
or this like the feeling on cigarettes
and off being sober it's like
the the it's so [ __ ] subtle that you
can't tell it's like caffeine
like when you're on a caffeine height
you're just like kind of messed out
because you're talking so fast
or talking a lot dude but it's still
it's still very close to being sober so
you can't tell but then the crazy thing
about how nicotine [ __ ] with you is
like i think till this day
i'm recovering from the years and
decades of smoking we're like damn i can
feel like oh this is how i'm supposed to
feel when i run this is how i'm supposed
to feel when i wake up in the morning my
blood flow everything like it's [ __ ]
insane and the anxiety and things that
you have on cigarettes it's
mind-blowingly different you're
constantly nervous it's like
you need cigarettes to just like feel
chill chill it's weird man well i hear
big tobaccos really [ __ ] like they're
really dark and the way they target
their customers and consumers they look
at them like they're [ __ ] scumbags
like there was a big campaign that they
had where they would only target
gays
poor people
and like that was what they would target
for ads and a lot of times i guess the
people that they target are like we
don't really see that many cigarette ads
anymore like not really but the people
that smoke they're targeted way more in
a lot more different ways and they will
really campaign to get those smokers to
keep smoking and it's like really scary
especially in the u.s right it's like
there's almost like what bart was saying
there's no benefit to smoking at all but
a lot a lot of these lobbyists for big
tobacco have worked their way to make it
seem that all these other health issues
are
not
big tobacco yeah it's not then
so and and we kind of think that way to
the point where
it's like well if you want to do it go
kill yourself when in reality it should
be like this should not be a thing at
all because there's no benefit didn't
they uh buy up like when jewel came out
didn't big tobacco buy yeah they like
bought out that company like majority
anyway or something like a huge lawsuit
for that or something like that too
though because like they got so many
kids
um to like they were like marketing
they're marketing to teens yeah i feel
like eventually though the whole thing
will just get
weeded out because even in cars you
don't really have a cigarette lighter
anymore you know it's just like that's
so true like bars a lot of them most of
you can't smoke at a bar you have to go
outside whereas before i was inside so i
just feel like it's just this gradual
decade by decade weeding out process wow
because it's not as cool anymore to do i
remember um
japan was like you could smoke
everywhere like there's restaurants
you're on the streets whatever and then
they decided to go
okay you can only smoke in designated
areas and almost over [ __ ] night like
a year after that i went to japan and
then like there's literally like next to
the train station there's a smoking
section and everyone just smokes there
and then nowhere in the streets are
people smoking and restaurants there's
like
there's going to be smoke-free
restaurants um and then they became like
there's there's full cities that are
like this is a smoke-free city so in
that whole entire city you can't smoke i
remember this there's a smoking section
on an airplane or smoking airplanes in
general like their every seat would have
an ashtray yeah
you know why they have an ashtray in the
bathrooms
is because when there are smokers that
need to have a cigarette they don't want
them to cause a fire
so they're like if you're gonna [ __ ]
do it anyway then there's something they
can even though you're not supposed to
this is no smoking but [ __ ] it just yeah
i feel like people would smell it though
if you smoked in did i tell you i almost
got in federal trouble for smoking on a
plane you were smoking on a plane so it
was a weed vape right and like this was
back when like we vapes were like kind
of new so like no vapes were getting
caught for anything they they weren't
even talking about like and also
e-cigarettes you know when they're
talking about like smoking all the
places not perimetered
and then they finally added that
includes
right so anyways i was on this uh this
flight to china
and uh i had done it a couple times i'm
not you're ballsy bro i know it's [ __ ]
up it's stupid i've never done it ever
since but um i i would hit my my vape at
like in the bathroom at the airport real
quick because it doesn't smell the smoke
goes way right away you know i was like
find random corners when you're just
you're traveling for like 15 hours in a
day you're just like tired right you
step out when you're on on layovers you
step out you hit a real kabab it's in
your bag you travel with it's all good
i got too brave one time and i remember
i was also hitting it on the back of
playing in the dark just one time worked
so once you do things you get confident
yeah you got a cocky guy finally i'm on
this flight to
trying to ride and i'm like [ __ ] dude
whatever it's the longest flight i go
into the bathroom
and uh i'm like all right let me i got
so cocky i'm so dumb i'm mid [ __ ] while
i'm doing this you should never do a
midship if you're gonna do anything like
that you should do it when you're done
so you don't have anything else to worry
about i'm [ __ ] hitting this thing
and i'm thinking i'm getting rid of the
the fumes and then the [ __ ] thing
goes
in the airplane in the airport oh my god
and this is a federal offense by the way
apparently anyways chinese federal ah
yeah and worse than china worse in china
were you going to china i was going to
china they treat weed like yeah like
it's really really bad heroin or some
[ __ ] yeah i didn't do this going to
china this is another country it wasn't
china
um
and so i have to [ __ ] i'm like wiping
my ass as fast as possible right to get
this thing out and i already hear
knocking on the door and like this
chinese stewardess hey bo ho right just
saying in chinese
this is this is my panic thinking
i literally once once i clear everything
out and i'm like good to go
i open the door and my mind goes i'm
going to yell first
so i start yelling at them i'm like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you guys alarm
right scared the [ __ ] at me i'm trying
to take a [ __ ] and you guys alarms going
off like crazy what the [ __ ] is going on
right you're a genius reverse psychology
both the guy the main series and then
the the lady stewardess are looking
they're kind of confused but they're
trying to look around at evidence
they're like you smoke i was like do you
[ __ ] smell cigarette smoke i'm taking
a [ __ ] and your alarm is going off like
and they didn't know what to make of it
because they only smelled [ __ ] yeah
what if they're like his [ __ ] is so
strong
[Music]
i'm like look look where my [ __ ]
cigarettes right my [ __ ] alarms going
scared give me a heart attack and then i
left
and then they're just like dumbfounded
for a second just like looking around
and i go back to my face
what are you thinking where did you put
your e-cigarette it was like
one of my other pockets but i was like
you see a cigarette did you see a lot or
anything you smell
and i just yelled at him as fast as i
could and i walked away dude you gotta
wait away with it got away with it
i would have been like [ __ ] locking
me up
that's smooth i'm going to jail dude
that's pretty good dude oh like it was
crazy that's pretty good that's the most
deviant thing i've ever heard you say
you did god bless for a greater good
though to not go to jail
you don't want to go chill in china bro
[ __ ] that you had to do that you're
[ __ ] jail proof anthony from now on
don't say that dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you